so what you're looking at right here is
my brand new game ready to hit the
charts called guess my number this is a
fascinating thrill-a-minute game where
the computer thinks of a number and I
try to guess what it is along the way it
gives me hints as to whether the numbers
should be higher or lower than my
previous guesses so you might be
thinking to yourself as I'm playing this
wow this looks really boring well it
might be but what if it looked a little
something like this yeah I've got a
little personalized welcome message here
in the front screen I've got some
achievements now that I can earn as you
can see I'm already earned my first
timer achievement and I am twenty-two
percent of the way towards completing my
100 guesses achievement and when I play
a game you'll notice that it's telling
me the number of games I have played so
far on this difficulty level and this is
being loaded from the cloud so I can
play in different devices and I can see
this number carry over from device to
device in addition I have leaderboards
now for each difficulty level here we
can see that I am in first place out of
all the people in my circles to play
this game which is really just me but
I'm also second place in the public
leaderboard and all this by the way is
cross-platform so on the Android version
of guests my number I could earn
progress towards these very same
achievements and I could compare leader
board scores against my friends no
matter what device they're on and when
I'm all done playing a game I have a
brag button that I can click which will
share my score on google+ and anybody
that clicks this little play button here
in my post will be taken to the very
same game on the very same difficulty
level with the very same secret number
to see if they can guess it in fewer
moves than I did so clearly now we've
gone from a boring old guessing game to
what I am sure is going to win several
game of the year awards in the category
of games where you have to guess a
random number so let's look at adding
these features achievements leaderboards
savegame the cloud adding
interactive posts on google+ to your own
iOS game and we can start by taking this
very same sample game and yes I'm going
to share this awesome source code with
you and build it up from the very
beginning so stick around this is going
to be fun and hopefully when we're all
done you'll have learned a little
something about adding Play game
services to your own game so I will see
you in the next lesson
Papa Papa